Hello and welcome.
It's July 26, 2023. We're here in
active inference Livestream 49.1
with Megan Peters and Nora Bradford. So
thank you both for joining. We're
looking forward to a presentation
followed by a discussion on clickbait
consciousness science and responsible
journalism. So, Megan, to you. Thank
you. And thanks so much, Daniel, for
having us. We're really happy to be here
and to chat about this. So I'll talk for
a little over ten minutes and then we'll
hopefully have a nice discussion here.
So, yeah, we're really happy to be here
because I think that this is a really
topical thing for us to be talking about
right now. It's very in the media. It's
really in response to the way the media
has been covering consciousness science
just in the past few weeks. So here we
go. I'll have a few things to share with
you. Okay, so since we're talking about
consciousness science, let's start with
a provocative question. So you are
conscious. How is this possible?
How is it possible that your brain
creates the conscious experience of you?
And so this is a captivating, and it's a
stimulating kind of crazy question.
It's a really huge question. It borders
on the religious and spiritual in many
ways. It borders on the cutting edge of
physics in many ways. And so the study
of this question and the field of
consciousness science more generally,
it's really straddling the border
between the natural sciences and
philosophy and spirituality in a way
that a lot of other domains maybe don't
need to do. And so, as a result, this
field of consciousness science, it
really captures the hearts and minds and
sometimes pretty wild imaginations of
all sorts of folks, as I said, from
psychologists and biologists and
neuroscientists all the way to computer
scientists and engineers to religious
and spiritual leaders. Basically anybody
who wonders about our origins or place
in the universe, why that we know that
we are here, why there is something that
it is like to be us. They are the people
who are interested in this question,
and that's probably a lot of people who
are listening and watching right now.
So it's actually really quite easy,
I think, to get swept up in the
sensational nature of this question.
Consciousness science is a really big
deal. It touches on so many aspects of
our everyday experience. And so this
kind of leads us to another version of
this question, which is, is this even
really science? Is this something that
can be even studied scientifically? Or
does it transcend beyond scientific
inquiry? Do consciousness scientists do
something that can be characterized
really as science? Or maybe they're
studying something that's a little bit
more on the border, like, I don't know,
telepathy or panpsychism,
like maybe rocks and trees are also
conscious. Wouldn't that be crazy? Or
maybe the vibrations of the mean that
the universe is conscious. So it kind of
quickly starts to feel a little fuzzy,
a little less scientific. And that's
what I want to talk about today, is that
perception and how that is kind of
exacerbated by the way that this field
is portrayed in the media and maybe what
we can do about it. Okay? And so all
this means that consciousness science is
really difficult, not just to do
scientifically, and it is really
difficult, I promise you, but it's also
really difficult from a social
perspective. So more than for some other
fields, those of us who do consciousness
science and who study this
scientifically, we have a really crucial
and difficult responsibility, which is
to accurately and precisely communicate
the state of our field and its methods
and its discoveries and how it relates
to other fields, from physics to
medicine and beyond. And it's in
fact, so difficult that our field has
actually written a number of papers
about just how difficult it is. So this
is a fairly recent paper TS colleagues,
including many others. This is just from
a few years ago. And these papers, and
this one in particular, really highlight
why our field in specific has kind
of an uphill battle compared to a lot of
other areas of study, especially when it
comes to potential misrepresentation in
the media. So I thought that maybe in
order to drive this point home, I could
actually give you some examples of how
consciousness science has been
misrepresented in the media so that we
can get a handle on this, we can see it
concretely. And as I'm giving you some
of these examples, I want you to try to
imagine how it would sound if the same
kinds of statements, the same kind of
sweeping claims were made about
discoveries in biology or chemistry,
neuroscience, climate science,
engineering, that kind of thing. All
right, let's do some examples. Here is
the first one. Okay, this is an example
which is actually 13 years old at this
point. As I think you'll see, maybe it
hasn't gotten so much better over the
past 13 years. But in this example, the
title Sizing of Consciousness by its
bits, we have Christoph Coke, who is an
expert on consciousness science at
Caltech, being quoted as saying, I love
his ideas. It's the only real promising
fundamental theory. And here,
deciding to present just this one
scientist's opinion as fact without
challenging it at all, without
presenting any other opinions at all,
I'll point out that this opinion was
actually not representative of the
consensus in the field at that time. It
was this one scientist's point of view,
and it's not actually representative of
the consensus in the field now either.
And so I want you to take this quote,
but I want you to replace consciousness
with curing cancer. So this opinion
presented as fact is akin to writing
that one scientist theory about a cure
for cancer is the only really promising
fundamental theory for curing cancer.
And without presenting any other
possibilities that maybe more work needs
to be done or more experiments need to
be run. This is really hyperbolic. And
it seems like maybe this kind of
hyperbole would be hopefully at least a
little less likely to happen in
biomedicine, or at least would receive
more pushback if it were presented this
way. So here's another example,
and this one's a bit more recent. So
this one's from 2018.
The Is.
Okay, so the electrical activity that
moves across neurons is sought by some
scientists to contribute to human
consciousness. This is like a perfectly
reasonable statement, right? Like
totally fine, totally legit. But then
the the journalist goes on to say, if
electrical activity is being disrupted
by anesthetic and plants too, causing
them to lose consciousness, does that
mean in some way that they are
conscious? Okay, so first of all,
these statements are pretty vague.
That's not really super surprising from
a popular science piece. And it's not
really the primary problem here, saying
that electricity that moves across
neurons thought to from
disruption of electrical activity to
plants being conscious. And this is
pretty sensational, kind of to the
extreme. And it makes this fuzzy border
between consciousness science and
pseudoscience, which is this border that
we are trying so hard to delete all the
time. It makes it even fuzzier. It gives
us an even harder problem to fight
against as consciousness. And this isn't
just happening 13 years ago, five years
ago. It's still why we're talking.
Just last month, there was this project
which was held in conjunction with the
association for the Scientific Study of
Consciousness annual meeting, which was
in New York City. And at this public
event, Christophe Coke, who you can see
here on the right, and Dave Chalmers
here's on the left, they presented their
25 year old bet about whether the neural
correlates of consciousness, the ones
that go up and down with consciousness
goes up and down, would be found.
And during this public event, some new
results were unveiled for the very first
time from one of the ongoing projects,
which was designed to challenge two of
the many theories about how
consciousness arises in the brain. And
those two theories are called the global
neuronal workspace theory and the
integrated information theory. And the
hot off the press results that were
shown in this event, they actually ended
up challenging both theories. They
showed that the neural correlates of
consciousness are still unknown, that
neither theory was really strongly
supported by the data that were
collected, and so on. But that's not the
story. That's not exciting. And so
that's not the story that the press
told. And so here is what the media
actually said. Okay, so first we're
going to start with Nature. Nature, the
journalism side of this flagship
scientific journal. You'd hope that they
would be pretty careful about their
scientific journalism, but instead they
write taglines like this, like
Christophe Wagered Dave, 25 years ago
that researchers would learn how the
brain achieves consciousness by now,
but the quest continues. But this is
actually not what the bet was about.
The bet was about the neural correlates,
not the causal mechanisms, not the
generative production of consciousness.
And remember as good are
not the same thing. And there's always a
relevant Xkcd. And so I direct you to
this one here, but it
gets worse. So here's what science had
to say. Advocates of the losing
idea are not conceding yet. So again,
neither idea lost, remember? Or rather
both of them lost. Neither one of them
won. Nobody lost. Nobody won. And so why
would science say that one of them lost
or is even losing? That seems a little
over the top. And so it kind of makes
you wonder, are they like trying to
drive clicks? Or what is the point here
of sensationalizing quite to this
degree? It seems like a bad idea. It
seems like oversimplification that
actually changes the meaning of what was
presented. So here's another example.
This is from the economist. This article
largely reported on a different event
that was actually part of the ASSC like
primary meeting. But it still
capitalized on the buzz that this public
event, this evening event created. And
it opens with this really kind of
terrible twist of the actual
experimental design. So The Economist
article says top of the bill was the
announcement of the result of a so
called adversarial collaboration between
proponents of two hypotheses about the
nature of consciousness. Again, not what
the bet was about. It wasn't about the
nature of consciousness. But anyway,
this involved running a series of
experiments begun in 2020 to determine
which, if either of them is correct.
But again, that's not what the
collaboration was designed to do,
right? In science, you can never prove
anything. You can never show you're
correct. You can only show that you are
not wrong or that you are wrong. That's
it. That's what you get in science.
Okay? So moreover,
all of these articles, the three that
I've shown you and a number of others,
they also contained essentially no
discussion of whether these two theories
global Neuronal Workspace Theory and
Integrated Information Theory, one of
which was losing, apparently, whether
they were the only ones worth
considering. So the articles didn't
really discuss anything else, any other
possible theories. In fact, the articles
called these two theories leading by the
media. But the truth is that they're
leading only in number of publications,
not in amount of scientific evidence
supporting them. They just have a lot of
publications out there. There's no
discussion in these articles beyond a
trivial passing mention that there are
any other theories out there at all.
And especially that whether they are
viable or not, whether they're
empirically supported. So here's some.
This isn't all of the empirically
supported theories of consciousness out
there. There's a really nice article
here by Anil Seth and Tim Bain that
came out last year that discusses a
bunch of these. And there's a really
nice article here by this group also
saying they actually looked at the
empirical support for different theories
of consciousness. How many papers are
out there that actually challenge versus
support each theory? And so this
landscape is the one that should be the
one to evaluate all of the results that
were presented at this event. In it
means that even if one of the two
theories that this one project was
looking at, if one of them didn't make
the cut, that doesn't mean the other one
wins. And is right. It just means that
one of them maybe lost. And it didn't
even lose, remember? In fact. So in
addition to these really nice papers,
there's also a whole series of these
adversarial collaborations from the same
funding agency as the one that was shown
in this public event that are designed
to actually pit these theories against
each other in a pairwise fashion, in a
Thunderdome style. For all you Mad Max
fans out there, I love old school
Sci-Fi. And the idea here is that two
theories enter and one theory leaves.
One theory survives, but it doesn't win
because there's another round coming.
And so all of these nuances, they were
just unfortunately missing from all the
news coverage. And I understand that
news likes to get people to read it and
it likes to be sensational, but the
missing aspect of the missing nuance
really changes the meaning of what was
presented. And that's actually a really
big problem here. And why is this such a
problem, you might ask? I'm getting
myself all worked up here, right? So the
answer to why I'm getting all worked up
really comes back to what I presented in
the beginning, which is that we
consciousness scientists have this
uphill battle we constantly have to
fight to legitimize our research
program. And importantly, this isn't
just in the eyes of the public. So it's
not just in the eyes of the people
reading these articles who are not part
of this scientific sphere. It's also in
the eyes of the scientific community,
more generally, of our funding agencies,
and maybe most importantly, our close
peers within adjacent fields. So imagine
for a second that you are on a hiring
committee at a university and you read a
candidate's description of their
research program and it is about
consciousness science. They have pages
and pages and several publications, and
they maybe have a grant that's about
consciousness science. But you, as the
member of the hiring committee, just
read this, this New York Times article
about how plants probably have
consciousness. And so maybe your eyes
are now rolling out of your head because
you've been primed to think this isn't
real, this is sensational, this isn't
something that can be studied
scientifically. You might as well be
talking about doing research on
telepathy. Is this really a colleague
that you want? So here's another
example. What if you're on a grant
review committee or you're reviewing a
paper and you just read these articles
in Science and in Nature that heavily
imply that there are only two real
theories of consciousness that have any
empirical support. But the paper or
grant that you're reviewing is not
targeting either one of these theories.
So now maybe you see the problem here.
These journalism articles, they're not
just infuriating. They're really
actively damaging the legitimacy of our
field. They're cutting us off at the
knees in the eyes of our peers in terms
of the financial support we can compete
for from granting agencies, in terms of
where we can publish our science. And by
the way, that science is state of the
art and cutting edge. We have a
responsibility, though, as people who
are doing this state of the art
consciousness science to try to work
with the media so that the reporting can
be more honest, so we can continue
working there as well. This is a two way
street in some ways, but we also hope
that folks who are listening right now
will recognize this pattern the next
time you read an article about
consciousness science that maybe those
sensationalized claims are not exactly a
reflection of the state of art in the
field. Because here is the truth. This
is real consciousness science, modern
consciousness science. It's a collection
of basically every single state of the
art discipline and method of scientific
inquiry that you can think of. So my
version of consciousness science that I
do in my lab is a conglomeration of
cognitive sciences and computational
neuroscience and a little bit of
computer science, artificial
intelligence, machine learning thrown
in. We also have heavy influences from
philosophy and psychology and
engineering and a little bit of
metascience, and we have neuroimaging,
and we have statistics. And this is
really a representation of consciousness
science, not just in my research group,
but the consciousness science being done
worldwide by thousands of people.
Consciousness science is right at the
center, right at the heart, the very
bleeding edge of our collective
scientific understanding. So remember
when I put this slide up before and I
said that the study of this question
straddles the border between natural
sciences and philosophy in a way that a
lot of other domains maybe don't need to
do. And as a result, it captures our
imagination. It gets out there, it gets
into your brain and your mind and sticks
there in a way that some other fields
might not. But maybe you can see through
what I've talked about today that the
challenges with communicating the crux
of this question and in doing the
science itself, that actually makes the
people who are doing this pretty brave,
especially the younger trainees. When
you think about it, they're fighting
this real uphill battle. So,
personally, me, I'm relatively safe. I
have job security. If people don't take
me seriously when I say I'm a
consciousness scientist, that's their
loss, that's fine. But the younger
people, the trainees in the field,
those who are trying to get jobs, those
who are trying to push the envelope of
what we know about our brains and our
minds and our awareness of ourselves in
this world, they've got a lot of
misperceptions to overcome. So if
you are excited and you want to know
more about the modern, exciting field of
consciousness Science, I suggest that
you head to the ASFC website. You can
have a look at the whole science
program. They've actually posted videos
of the keynotes from this year, so
that's pretty cool. You can go and see
some of those. You can also check out
the plan for the future. And of course,
if I've inspired you even a little bit
to find out about consciousness science
yourself. Despite my kind of rant here,
I say welcome. Please come join us.
There's a lot of people doing some
really cool stuff, really amazing, mind
blowing stuff, working to figure this
out. So please come join us.
Absolutely, the more the merrier. And so
I think I will stop there and just say
if you've enjoyed this talk or anything
that I said resonated with you, I've got
a real short little piece here. It's
about 800 words, so not a long homework
assignment. You can go and check that
out. So I think I'll stop and pass the
mic back to Daniel. And also welcome
Nora Bradford, who is a doctoral student
here at UC Irvine, who works in
Consciousness Science, but who also is
an accomplished science journalist who's
written articles in Scientific American
Science News, Discover, and many more.
So thanks very much.
Laura, maybe to you for a first
reflection about what you see there or
how you came to be here. Yeah, sure.
Yeah. So I was at ASC and went to the
event that was associated with ASSC,
but not run by ASSC, just to be clear.
And it was really exciting to see
consciousness science kind of being
celebrated in the way that it was. I had
some issues with the event, but overall
I was very excited that it was getting
this public attention. Right. And then
afterwards, I was again excited to see
that people were writing about my field,
because that journalism.
Things I'm immediately
disappointed by wrong.
Yeah. And I guess I started to think
about kind of why conscious science is
maybe a harder journalist to
cover. And I think there is just
probably a lot more controversy and a
lot more room for mistakes to be made
than perhaps in fields where the
research is more clear cut or more
easily interpretable. So, yeah,
I think there's a lot as journalists and
also as researchers from this.
Yeah. Can I just really quickly follow
up and say I think that, Nora, you're
spot on by saying that,
by presenting the idea that it's the
interpretation that's part of the
problem here. It's not just that people
are maybe getting facts wrong when
they're writing about this field. It's
that the interpretations are really
nuanced, they're really difficult to get
right, and it's really easy for an
oversimplification to end up
fundamentally changing the meaning in
this space in a way that maybe doesn't
occur quite as often in some other
fields.
Yeah, that's really interesting to kind
of disentangle the features that make
this a unique, although also exemplary
case of communicating challenging ideas.
I mean, the first that presents itself
to me is just how much is on the table?
Whose pain matters? Whose experiences or
what experiences even matter? What's the
difference between a who and a what?
This is the real question. If something
doesn't have an experience, then there's
no feeling. But if something does have
an experience, then it's a feeling and
it's a morally culpable or something
that we're responsible for treating in
an ethical way. So it's like whether or
not it's always brought up in those
articles, the stakes are so high,
whereas whether a given molecular
compound does this molecular interaction
is closer to the objective. Whereas this
is the ultimate subjective question,
seemingly. Sure, yeah,
I agree with you definitely that the
ethical stakes, the moral implications
of this field are just staggering.
And certainly it's not unique in that
way that the ethical and moral
implications of sociological research or
of climate science or of many other
domains also have these staggering
implications. I think one of the
biggest challenges that we have is not
just in the interpretation of objective
data, but exactly, as you've just said,
that this is the ultimate subjectivity,
that the thing that we are studying by
its definition is not objectively
observable. And that is
absolutely something that is at
least you can design measurement tools
in a way that have different
philosophical foundations in basically
every other field. But by its very
nature, by the definition of subjective
experience, we cannot design a
measurement tool that actually says,
what is it like to be you? That's kind
of the whole problem. But your
points also about the ethical
implications in medicine, the difference
between a who and a what. I think that
that's also really important to bring
up, that here we are trying to I've
presented this as like we want to
understand consciousness. And I never
really defined consciousness. I just
said, like, here's consciousness and
here's an umbrella term and you take
that kind of how you want. But it's true
that consciousness science spans all the
way from wakefulness versus coma or
locked in syndrome or traumatic brain
injury. Anesthesia all the way through
to is a baby conscious? Is a fetus
conscious? Is an AI conscious? Is a
cockroach or your dog,
or 200 years ago, people might argue
that children were less conscious than
adults and so it was okay to hit your
children because they wouldn't feel it
as much or something. And so there's a
lot of sociological and ethical and
moral implication in everything that
we're doing. Which is why one of the
reason I've chosen this field, too, is
that it really scratches a lot of
intellectual itch. But it also feels
really important, especially right now,
with the rise of machine intelligence
and with ongoing debates about animal or
fetal consciousness that really bear
extreme impact on legislation,
on moral decisions that we make as a
people. So, yeah, it's a big thing that
we're doing. I'm a little biased, but it
is a big thing. And I would add that
even if researchers are sometimes good
at explaining what they mean by
consciousness in their research, like to
a journalist, say, the journalists are
not always necessarily great at
communicating that to the public through
their writing. And I get why that would
be hard. It can be clunky, it can be
awkward and unappealing to explain. But
that is crucial because people readers
can take it however they want based on
how they're interpreting the word
consciousness. So I think that's super
important to address if you're writing
about consciousness.
Yeah, it's really a field that's kind of
a leading indicator because,
especially if approached in a scientific
way, in our current setting,
a scientific understanding of X is what
shapes evidence driven policy about X.
So I guess this leads to what is
or would or could be a science driven
approach. Like, how do we know it when
we see it? When someone is approaching
this question from a scientific
perspective, what would each of you say
to this? Well, I'm going to give kind of
the stock answer, which is that you want
to have objective measures that are
valid and reliable, but the big one is
falsifiability and that's any student of
science going back to grade. School is
going to learn a little bit about that,
which is that if you've got a theory or
you've got a hypothesis about how,
let's say, the brain generates
consciousness, or even going back to
just correlates, just like, which bits
of the brain are correlated
in their activity with whether you're
more conscious or less conscious. So
let's keep it really very basic. You
need to have it be falsifiable. You need
to say it's this area of the brain that
will correlate and not that area of the
brain. And the recognition
that an absence of evidence is not
evidence of absence is also really
crucial to this idea, which is that just
because I failed to measure a
correspondence between the activity and
the bit of the brain, that I
hypothesized and some measure of
awareness that I get from self report
doesn't mean that that area of the brain
isn't doing the work. It just means that
our machines are terrible or that our
measure sucks. And honestly,
despite the state of the art
measurements that we do have, we have
millimeter level precision in humans,
we have cellular level precision in non
human animals, we can record a lot of
stuff, and we have a lot
of really fancy machine learning
algorithms to help us extract what that
stuff means. To go from super high
dimensional noisy data down to something
that we can maybe make the argument is
interpretable. Interpretable.
Yeah. But just because you didn't
find what you were looking for doesn't
mean that it's not there. It just means
that you were maybe looking in the wrong
place or that you were looking using the
wrong tool. And so these kind of go
hand in hand because on the one hand,
you want your hypothesis to be
falsifiable, so you aren't allowed to
just say, oh, well, I just wasn't
looking for it the right way, so I'm
just going to revise how I'm looking and
try again. And therefore I'm still
right. You need to design your
experiments and your theories such that
if you find a particular result, a
positive result, then it actually
disproves your theory as opposed to just
failing to provide support for your
theory. So I think that
those and other kind of standard
criteria that you might find in any Stem
classroom that demonstrate the
scientific method, those are probably
the definitions that I would fall back
on. And I think that consciousness and
science, broadly speaking, the stuff
that is present at the ASC, it does all
of that, it absolutely does. It's the
same caliber of computational
neuroscience and neuroimaging and
psychological psychophysics measurement
and logical philosophy approaches that
you would find at any other flagship
conference in the world. Yeah.
And I would say if you're reading an
article rather than like a journal
paper, like if you're reading something
in the press, the way to know if it's
trustworthy or not, or one way is if
it's making sensational claims, like
claiming to have found the root of
consciousness or some really large
claim. It's probably not true. I think
that wouldn't happen in one study, I'm
assuming. So just read with a skeptical
eye and if you feel
comfortable, try to read the primary,
like get inspired by the press. But if
you feel like there's something off,
just go to the primary literature and
see what's up and see if you can
interpret it for yourself. It's
understandable if you can't, but yeah,
that's what I would say. That's a good
rule of thumb, Nora, that one study is
never going to be the answer in any not
just ours, but it's easy to get swept
away in the sensational claims and to be
like, OOH, they found the neural cause
of probably. Yeah,
yeah. And I would say like pre
registration also. I mean, Megan, I
don't know what your rule of thumb is
for this, but if people,
you know, plan for the study and how
they're going to analyze it ahead of
time, that is usually a really good
sign. I mean, basically what you're just
saying, but just like stamp of we
promise we did this. Ahead of time kind
of thing avoids.
Harking after the fact, right?
Yeah, it was kind of cool to see
metascience and also
maybe kind of bibliographic analyses
looking at different trends in
literature, but then also going beyond
the peer reviewed literature to looking
at the real trends that influence people
who are outside of the profession. And I
don't know if canary in the coal mine is
the right bird in the right niche here,
but it's like proposing unobservables
is commonplace in research, like latent
cause analysis and any kind of
structural equation modeling. And here
is the tour de force of unobservables,
maybe that which is defined as
unobservables. And so it's actually like
a space to bring up all these pieces of
epistemic hygiene about from
preregistration to the pace and the tone
of the scientific community and
questions of multidisciplinarity in
research.
And then there's a heart at the
intersection of the Venn diagram where
it kind of all comes together. It's
like, well, this synthesis cannot happen
without all these pieces. If we're not
having philosophers in conversation with
the statisticians, then this synthesis
can't happen. Now, maybe the synthesis
that you care about doesn't need that,
but we care about this and this
synthesis requires it. So we need to
develop the approaches and the
communication around that.
It's really a tip of the spear effort
even apart from the consequences of the
research. What a heartwarming
sentiment. Thank you for sharing that.
I love the phrase epistemic hygiene
because that is so crucial, I think, to
every field. But it's like particularly
aggressively exposed in this field,
which is exactly why I think that my
science has benefited so powerfully
from close collaboration with
philosophers and with statisticians. I
mean, this is kind of the space that I
live in here in the cognitive sciences
department is we're halfway between AI
and philosophy and psychology and
neuroscience and engineering and it's
kind of at, like where all these things
come together. But then this metascience
thing, I'm happy that you picked up on
that because I think that it's also
really the bibliometric analyses
are really critical and we're at this
crazy spot and have been for a long time
now. But I think it's really coming to a
head where the vast majority of
our scientific knowledge is not
accessible to any one researcher simply
because there's so much of it, right?
You can't read all of the literature.
You can't even read all the literature
that's in your tiny little corner. And
consciousness science, like many other
fields in this way, actually is one of
those that brings together a lot of
different fields. So it makes it even
harder for you to keep up with the
things that are going to be really
relevant. I mean, you have to keep up
with the cutting edge tools in
neuroimaging data analysis, plus the
epistemic hygiene that the philosophers
are going to bring, plus cutting edge
behavioral paradigms and what they mean
in naturalistic data collection
settings. So that you're not just
saying, oh, I've discovered something
fundamental about consciousness by
showing you gabor patches all day? And I
say this as someone who shows people
gabor patches all day, but it's
a real challenge to bring together all
these things. And maybe you're right.
Maybe that consciousness science is I
don't know about the canary in the cold
mine, so to speak, but maybe you're
right that it's one of the places where
you can really see all these cogs
working together to come at one major
question. Or maybe you don't quite see
the need for that hygiene in some other
fields, yet it still is. There like
latent cause analysis is not just
something that we do in consciousness
science or neuroscience. We do it in
economics, we do it in sociology. We do
it, like, everywhere. And so having a
real handle on how to design stuff that
actually asks the questions that you're
interested in is something that I
find that I have to continuously work
hard to keep in my sights.
And I'm lucky that we've got a pile of
philosophers that we get to hang out
with who blow into your talk and
say everything that you just said is
wrong. And here's why. Here's this
logical hole in what you've done. And
they're right. And it's great because it
makes the science better.
And you don't typically get philosophers
blowing into a talk in a lot of other
fields. It doesn't happen. And I
think it should. We all
have that inroad to our experience.
So it's something that integrates across
disciplines, kind of even cast the
disciplinary organizational paradigm
into at least critical light and
then goes even outside of academia
because these are what people search
engine for and language model,
discuss. And I think it is one of
these. It's like an itch that some can't
scratch with this inscrutable and
ineffable nature that does verge into
the mystical. So what do we do with the
huge mystery that
makes it a training and exhibition
field? Again, that's not just
important, but is kind of the
archetype of how do
you have a multidecade conversation with
potentially non compatible theorizing?
Whereas in many of the physical
sciences, including physical or
reductionist perspectives on
neuroscience, threads open and
close, little bit quicker, little bit
easier, tend to not delve
into ancient history, tend to not
need to invoke world knowledge
traditions. So that makes
it fun. It makes it fun and useful. And
if something's fun and useful, what
secret third thing are we looking for
exactly? Sounds like if you weren't
already a consciousness scientist,
maybe we've converted you a little bit.
As only a bug doctor. I did
one work on the Ant colony and
definitions of consciousness, and we
didn't come down on the issue of whether
the nest mates are conscious under what
definition or the colony. But more
pointed out, well, if you define it
according to some mammalian
neuroanatomy, then you kind of already
know what the answer is going to be.
It's going to be no. And if you define
it according to a specific primate
centered symbolic communication
approach, again, you know what that's
going to be? It's no. If you define it
based upon some generic informational
property, then you already know
what it's going to be. It's going to be
on that continuum. And so we kind of
tried to flip the approach by instead of
asking which feature
would help us differentiate whether the
ant colony is conscious or not, we just
said, let's just look at what the
features that people are using and then
ask whether colony is. But we don't have
the 1 meter metal bar for consciousness.
So again, it's like, well, let's say
seven out of ten that we observed. We
don't know how many other unproposed
theories there are. So seven out of ten
could be total sampling bias.
Even if it was ten out of ten, then what
would that type of consensus really
mean?
And that's where our road took us.
And I saw that conclusion as like,
a chance to broaden the discussion.
But discussions are not only about
broadening, because there's real
decisions that are being made. So it
can't only be yes.
And and I think that when you connect it
back to falsification and all of these
other properties, that's where we get
the winnowing. But it's those two
complementary conversations, like the
broader inclusion of perspectives
that expands the space that we can
comprehend and then the diligence
that also shrinks it back down and
somehow will zigzag to better and better
understandings.
You your point about we
don't have a yardstick, we don't have a
metal rod, right, that know how
conscious I mean, like, according to
some folks, we have that metal rod, and
we've surpassed that with, for example,
large language models.
And we're not just talking particular
Google engineers who decide to get
really excited about how their pet
language model is conscious. We're
talking any kind of
reasonable interpretation of the old
school Turing test would be passed
by existing language models right now,
in fact, arguably, it might have been
passed long ago with Eliza in,
like, the if it wasn't passed
with Eliza, then certainly it has been
passed now. But I think that there is a
growing understanding that information
processing capacity and intelligence are
not the same thing as internal
phenomenal experience, and that the
tests that we have, to the extent that
we have any tests at all, are woefully
inadequate and, as you said, are locked
to particular implementations. So you
can't apply the mammalian test for
consciousness, like, oh, I'm looking for
this particular neural signature, which
tells me whether the monkey is
anesthetized or not, and I can't apply
that to ants and expect it to work.
It's not going to tell me anything
useful there. Can't necessarily apply it
to octopuses either for the record. So
we're not even going insects. We're
going other arguably incredibly
intelligent beings that can open jars
and be sneaky and do all sorts of cool
stuff and
that have complex social interactions
and are basically aliens. This is
my professional scientific opinion here,
but they basically are, right? Like,
they're so fundamentally, physically
different from us. And so any
consciousness ometer that we develop for
us or that applies in monkeys or even in
dogs or cats is not really going to
apply there. And so differentiating
tests for intelligence, from tests from
inner experience is a really difficult
problem. And then there's the third
problem, which is a test for whether we
attribute consciousness to an agent,
which, if you saw the movie Ex Machina,
is the Garland test.
So that's do never mind whether it
actually has consciousness, do I
attribute consciousness to it? Because
that is going to change how we interact
with it and the rights that we ascribe
to it and so on. And so I think we're
well past the point at which we need to
get a better handle on this. Some of the
stuff that I'm working on right now is
moving in this direction. Not just me
and a huge group of lots of other
people. And I think Joshua Bengio gave
testimony to Congress, like today about
the need for increased regulatory
oversight of who has access to
so called artificial intelligence models
so that we can better understand how
their implementation and their
interaction with humans might exacerbate
biases or cause all sorts of other
problems. So you can actually go and
read his testimony that he gave. I don't
remember where the link is. Go find it.
But he had a summary and then he linked
to the testimony. And I think that
having folks like Yahshua and other
giants in the field speaking out about
the need for actually tackling this and
this isn't just a philosopher's
playground to talk about consciousness.
This is, as you said, the testing bed
for where the rest of science is going.
And it's also very topical right now.
So what does that healthy
conversation look like in the case of
the synthetic intelligences and language
models and all of this?
What does that continuum look like
between the actual measures and proxies
that we use in research and what
memes or themes or words that I
guess, by definition aren't popular
today, like big data wasn't popular till
it was. So something
like what has to come on the scene and
come into the lab, do you think, to
support the kind of work and knowledge
that either of you would want to see?
This isn't an answer to your question,
but it just reminded me of one thing
that we need less of, is people writing
about these interactions with AI that
are like, my AI told me that it wanted
to get married, or like, my AI,
whatever. It's not useful. It's not
news. Stop reporting about it. That's
all I have to say. Okay. Go ahead,
Megan. No, I wanted you to take this
too, because I think that this question
is about communication in a way that
you're much more embedded in the science
communication space than I am. And so
for I think one
possible way to go about this that maybe
you can speak to would be what kinds
you're Daniel, you're talking about what
do we need to bring into the lab? Maybe
communication tools is one of those or
ways of communicating this science ways
of and to different audiences. And so
maybe, Nora, you've got some ideas.
You've done so much in this space. I
don't I mean, I guess what
we've been talking about with people who
study human consciousness,
people who study consciousness and other
entities as well, just being clear about
what you mean by consciousness. Do you
mean a subjective experience? Do you
mean basically is a light on or off?
Do you mean awake versus asleep?
Just being really clear about what level
you're talking at, I think is really
helpful. Again, when you're just
presenting your research, whether it's
on Twitter or you're talking to a
journalist, really being clear cut about
that so that people can't make kind of
extrapolations from your work that your
work doesn't cover I don't know what
else? Yeah, I guess just being willing
to also talk about your work. I feel
like a lot of data science feels pretty
inaccessible to the general public. So
finding ways to communicate what you do
and how you're conducting your work is
helpful. Being open about it.
Yeah, there's a lot of Jargon in our
field too. In any field, there's Jargon.
But the oversimplification this is going
back to what we talked about at the
beginning. The oversimplification of
jargoning terms in our field seems
particularly susceptible to creating
a situation where the facts haven't
changed, but the interpretation has.
And so I think it's almost like
sensitivity training for anybody who's
in this space. Like just kind of a
tutorial that you can do that's like a
two hour click through thing. It's like,
here are all the ways in which
communicating this type of science,
due to its nature, is more
challenging than you might.
So my own involvement in
a program run by the Canadian Institute
for Advanced Research has given me a
little bit of training in speaking with
the media. And I would never say that I
am an expert in this at all. I will only
say that it was eye opening and
it was very useful in the clarity of
language that you are used to using the
precision of language that you're used
to using in a close scientific sphere
versus when you're speaking to a more
general audience. And when you're
speaking to a journalist or with several
journalists who are then going to be
writing for a more general audience.
It's a different mindset. It's a
different way of speaking. And even just
being aware of that, I think is really
useful. It's not that one is better than
the other. It's just that they are very
different. And that when we are training
to be scientists, when we're doing a PhD
in a field related to this, speaking to
the general public is not a skill that
gets pressed on. It's not a skill that
gets part of your professional
development training. Maybe you do like
one practice talk somewhere, but it's
not typically part of a general training
protocol. And so speaking to non
specialists, speaking to the media,
speaking to high school audiences,
speaking to your mom at the dinner
table, learning how to do this
effectively can actually be really
valuable and really rewarding and really
powerful. And again, I would never say
that I am an expert at this. At this
point. I just like to think that I'm a
little better at it than I otherwise
would be had I not had it drilled into
me how careful I need to be. I would
also say, don't be scared to email
journalists if you see that something's
inaccurate, know, speak up like Megan
has done about kind of how things are
portrayed inaccurately. Because,
yeah, as a like, no one's ever done that
to me, but if something was inaccurate,
I would want to know and I would want to
fix it, like ASAP. So don't feel bad
about emailing journalists. They want
their pieces to be accurate as well. So
that's what I would add, that can add to
the conversation. It would make me feel
a little bad about calling out the
pieces that I did in the presentation
and the piece of writing that I did too.
But at the same time, they put this in
writing, and this is wrong.
I don't like making people upset and I
don't like making people angry.
But it's out there in the world, and
it's not a million eyeballs, and that's
a problem. And so we're hoping your
viewership is about a million, right,
Daniel? So give or take low millions.
Low millions. So this will cover
everybody who read those articles,
right? It's really
interesting. The field is about
awareness of other minds, our own
mind, but also awareness of other minds
in theory. But then in practice,
awareness of other minds is
communication. Because if we say
something that it's like, well, I
wouldn't be annoyed by that, or I
wouldn't be angry with that. But you
missed the point of communication,
which it's not about what you would
think about it, it's about who the
recipient would be. So it's kind of like
the theory and the practice of
situational awareness about different
minds, all of which are different than
our own. Some are potentially radically
different than our own. Others might be
more similar.
So there's really maybe even a
quintessential relationship between
consciousness studies and
communication studies, which provides a
really unique two
way street that
the world is swerving into that two lane
highway with these questions that are
grabbing people's. Salience,
what are your sort of closing thoughts
or directions or what are some exciting
areas that you'd like to see unfolding
in the coming months and years?
Well, I'll go first.
Yeah, first of all, I think you're spot
on by saying communicating
consciousness, science being about
knowing about other minds. I mean, it's
like effective communication is theory
of mind, and theory of mind may have a
lot to do with modeling other minds and
modeling your own mind. And yes,
absolutely, it's all wrapped up. So I
think for me, getting this right
going forward or continuing to work
towards getting it right is a priority
for me. And one of the pieces
scientifically that I'm working on that
I hope to then communicate effectively
when we get it right. Or several of the
pieces is I have a couple of
these really wonderful large
collaborative projects where we're
working on everything from figuring out
how you would actually measure
consciousness effectively or what it
might even take to measure consciousness
effectively in other entities that are
not necessarily, like, awake, behaving,
healthy, adult human beings all the way.
To let's actually design some
experiments to test several different
theories of consciousness. Let's design
new some of what Nora's working on
actually, is designing new measurement
approaches to say, well, we need to
actually have a quantitative handle on
the things that we're talking about. So
this becomes objective, it becomes
falsifiable. We can do model
arbitration. So all these things I'm
really excited about, but overarching
all of those is this idea of going
it's all connected, right? You talked
about how consciousness science might be
this leading edge or wavefront of how
interdisciplinary science and
metascience needs to be done going
forward as we become even
more theory driven in some of our
scientific lines of inquiry than we have
been in the past, and more interested in
latent variables and causal discovery
and so on and so forth. And as the
science teams get bigger and more
complicated and the jobs within those
science teams become more specialized
and we have more and more need for
interdisciplinary collaboration, we're
going to have to change how we do team.
Science and how we do credit assignment
within team science in a way that I
think might end up being kind of
incompatible with the nice, siloed,
cute departmental structure that we have
in our universities. And so a
focus on not just tolerating, but
celebrating interdisciplinarity,
celebrating team science, doing credit
assignment correctly, and saying
first author isn't the only thing that
matters, that it really matters. If you
wrote this gorgeous software package
that facilitated a whole bunch of stuff
that's also a meaningful and powerful
contribution. Even if you didn't get
first author on that paper, you still
deserve a lot of credit. So I think that
there's a lot of shaking up that we need
to do about how we do science going
forward. And I really like the idea of
using consciousness science as a case
study. I think that's beautiful. And
thank you very much for making that
lovely connection, because it really
locks together a lot of the things that
I've been thinking about recently as
well. So there's my parting comments.
Yeah. I was also going to bring up these
huge projects that you're part of and
that other people are part of. It's
really exciting to see so many people
working together in these huge teams. I
feel like it just makes science so much
more efficient and more careful. So
that's very cool. Another thing I'm
hoping is that one, that journalists
don't get scared of covering conscious
of science from this. I think we'll
learn from our mistakes and we'll move
forward. I don't think we'll get scared,
but I hope that there's more coverage of
this field. And I also hope that
something that I've noticed about
science journalism is they really like
to just have clear cut findings because
that's the simplest thing to communicate
to people. But I think we can, as a
society, learn to be comfortable with
the ambiguity a little bit more,
especially when it comes to conscious
science. We might have found something,
but we're not sure, and that's okay.
And that's science. It's okay if your
headline isn't snappy and clear.
It's important for it to be clear, but
snappy and I guess have one takeaway
point. It's okay if it doesn't have a
takeaway point. Yeah,
I think that's what I'm excited about.
New era of science journalism.
Well, it sounds like bigger teams,
bigger community, more theory, more
data, more philosophy, more ambiguity.
It'll be a great time.
More philosophy, more ambiguity. Love
it. Yes. Thank you, Megan and Nora,
for joining. Always welcome
back. So till next time.
Yeah. Thank you so much. This has been
really a pleasure. Thanks for having us.
Thanks. Thank you.